[Music]
a traveler sits at the center of a
tangled mess of wires switches power
packs and flickering lights
outside insects Buzz as the sun creeps
up through the clear morning Sky The
helmeted Stranger checks the readouts
from the dials arrayed around them
confirming the Hermetic seal between the
Pod and the environment outside already
they start to feel the cool recycled air
circulating through the cramped space a
welcome relief from the stifle of the
Australian summer beyond their capsule
testing the controls in front of them
they push the levers back and forwards
everything seems to be working and on
the screen before them is confirmed the
most important readings of all the
current date and time and their target
year four and a half billion years ago
when this young Adventurer first stepped
into the Pod there hadn't even been sure
the computer would accept a Target date
so far in the past for they are not an
Explorer or a historian but a
paleontologist having spent their life
studying the history of the earth
reading the rocks and fossils and
imagining bygone Worlds the time
machines finally offered an opportunity
to see them with their own eyes to
experience the air the ocean and the
life forms first hand and this
paleontologist wants to see it all
starting from the very beginning we're
starting out here in the humid Western
Australian air they reason that they
have the best chance of finding Solid
Ground at their destination since these
rocks are some of the oldest in the
world flicking switches to begin the
boot up sequence they double check the
target date once again four and a half
billion years should take them right to
the beginning of our planet's story
and what better vantage point from which
to view the entire history
of the Earth
and so finally with all indicators in
the green and their heart beating hard
in their chest their Journey Begins With
the final push of a big red mechanical
button
[Music]
through the curved glass windows in
front of them they see the bright disk
of the sun which had almost reached its
Zenith now begin to slink down towards
the horizon retracing its path
it moves slowly at first but as they
watch its descent accelerates and all
too soon the sky is darkening in a blue
reverse Dawn
then it is night on the star's wheel
backwards through the desert sky before
fading in a rapid Dusk and orange sunset
this time the previous day the sun
barrels across the sky barely even
leaving a mark on The Time Traveler's
retinas Knight follows day with
increasing rapidity until the days and
nights themselves blur into a singular
bluish gray Haze the current date on
their screen Scrolls back first by
months then years as the scenery begins
to shift
trees shrink back to the ground Rocky
outcrops grow and reassemble as the
years turn to decades centuries
Millennia when millions of years are
ticking by with every passing second
even the landscape becomes a blur
suddenly in the darkness for the first
time a seed of Doubt takes root in their
determination to see this journey
through to satisfy their curiosity have
they perhaps rushed in too fast have
they properly considered the risks were
they properly prepared will they and the
layers of metal and glass that stand
between them and the hurtling Gulf of
time even be able to survive on the
early Earth
indeed when would they even find an
error in which they'd be able to remain
but it is too late already the time
machine is sounding its warnings that
the target date is approaching the
passage of Millennia and centuries slows
there is now no choice but to look out
and face the past
[Music]
foreign
ize land until the Earth was almost 4
billion years old so if you were taking
a stroll more than a billion years ago
protecting your privacy would probably
be the last thing on your mind yet today
we are surrounded on all sides by
intrusions into our personal lives this
video has been kindly sponsored by
nordvpn the fastest VPN out there and
they are the best choice if you want to
protect your data nor would have next
Generation encryption and are also more
than only a VPN they also have great
services like nordpass which helps
manage passwords and Nord Locker which
is great for cloud storage nordvpn
itself has a special threat protection
shield and can help protect you from
fishing malware ransomware and much more
and of course it's fantastic if you want
to explore streaming services in other
countries personally I found it very
useful as I live in Spain and there are
a better range of documentaries
streaming on us networks so head over to
nordvpn.com forward slash Earth or click
the link in the description to give Nord
a try it's risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee thanks to nordvpn
for supporting educational content on
YouTube
[Music]
the universe is a few hundred million
years old vast clouds of hydrogen and
helium gas created just a few minutes
after the big bang draw together into
clumps that are dense enough of their
hearts for nuclear fusion to begin for
the first time Stellar nurseries grow to
become globular star clusters which
themselves draw together and begin to
rotate flattening into a disc and
drawing out the characteristically
curving arms of a spiral galaxy and thus
our Milky Way galaxy is born by 5
billion years ago many generations of
stars have already lived and died and
the initial flurry of new star births
within the galaxy has tailed off to a
trickle and yet in a fragmented curving
arm 25 000 light years from the galactic
center one such late Kamas sputters into
life in the heart of a nebula filled
with the heavy Elemental shrapnel from
other long distant Stars the new Star
soon grows to a modest size orange
yellow sun surrounded like the entire
galaxy writ in miniature by a swirling
disc of gas and dust as gravity draws
the particles within that disc together
they grow to Pebbles to Boulders and
eventually to Rocky icy and gassy worlds
that continue their unruly really
rotations
for a Time chaos Reigns among these
newborn worlds as they jostle orbits
grappling for dominance among the
Clutter of planetary detritus a and so
it remains for as much as a hundred
million years before the victors emerge
Rocky worlds scarred glowing oozing but
rotating freely and uncontested and in
the third such orbit positioned about
150 million kilometers away from the
young sun is a rocky world that will
eventually change its face entirely and
become host to the most precious of all
cosmological creations
and so as the time machine decelerates
to a stop the traveler opens their eyes
onto the hadian Earth
to find it every bit as hellish as its
namesake
where the sky before had been a blurred
gray blend of blue day and started night
now day and night is not so clear
the heavens remain dim even when the
yellow sun sees its slowing line across
the sky there is much less atmosphere to
disperse and diffract the sunlight and
the traveler is thankful for the strong
rubber seals that hold the pressure of
air inside against the vacuous
deficiency Beyond
there is atmosphere out there but it is
a thin layer of hydrogen and helium and
the faint blue tinge to the unclouded
sky is offset by an orange glow from the
dark ground itself
a cacophony of alarms begin to sound
inside the capsule warnings of unstable
ground high temperatures shuddering
impacts it is clear that this far back
so close to Earth's creation the planet
is far from hospitable its glassy black
volcanic surface is thin enough to be
easily broken by upswelling bubbles of
magma and is shattered into a chaotic
molten plane as far as the eye can see
everything is sharp and angular there is
no water or air substantial enough to
round out Boulders and the constantly
shifting surface breaks and fuses broken
basil to new
and in the sky there are hints of
another agent of Destruction as well as
meteors streak their fiery lines across
the dim Dome most explode or burn out
before reaching the surface but others
mercifully distant from the Traveler's
pod splashed down into the Rock and
magma sending a spray of orange liquid
and clattering rocks
adrenaline and fear are finally enough
to overcome curiosity as the alarms ramp
up their pitch and urgency frantically
diving in a new Target date The Traveler
punches the start button with a bald
fist not a moment too soon suspended in
a safe bubble of time dilation the Pod
is unaffected as the scorching ground
opens up beneath it
[Music]
as it speeds forward in time the machine
now Bears the melted and charred scars
of its close encounter and the
paleontologist breathes a sigh of relief
in retrospect perhaps jumping headlong
into the late heavy bombardment hadn't
been the best of ideas when the time
machine slows again approaching the new
date of 3.5 billion BCE it is as if it
is arriving on an entirely different
planet
where before the sky had been dim and
star-studded even in the day it is now
hazy blue even Orange in Parts white and
gray clouds of every shape and size
build fortresses high in the atmosphere
where before the land had been a broken
and shattered firmament of rock and
magma there is now a smoothly rippled
expanse of Deep Blue Water
the capsule Bobs gently with each
passing wave
but this is the Earth
the archaean Earth some billion years
after the chaos of planetary formation
and in that short time the true
habitability of the Third Rock from our
sun has already begun to be realized
the Earth occupies a privileged place
within the solar system positioned not
so close to the fires of its star that
water evaporates away and not so far
away that it freezes into impenetrable
ice only here in our thin orbital band
is it possible for these oceans to exist
but something doesn't quite add up the
sun is still barely more than a thousand
million years old and has not yet
matured and come into its full
Luminosity its light shines only three
quarters as brightly and as warmly as it
will in Modern Times And so the
temperature on the planet's surface
shouldn't be quite this Clements
there should be icebergs and a distinct
chill in the air but the capsule's
instruments actually register a
temperature around 30 degrees Celsius
not so different from the tropical heat
our traveler left behind in Australia
but why the solution to this climatic
conundrum is to be found in the hazy sky
above
after their close call in the hadian The
Traveler is not taking any chances and
rather than daring to venture out they
make use of the onboard instruments to
measure everything they can about the
air and water beyond the Pod the water
turns out to be a very pleasant
temperature for swimming but is slightly
more acidic than the oceans of the
modern era nothing so strong as to burn
the skin but with a phkin to that of
orange juice it is drinkable the agent
of this acidity is carbonic acid the
same substance that is causing Reef
killing acidification in the modern
oceans and the carbonic acid in the
archaean Seas while not yet having any
reefs or really any life at all to
jeopardize actually has the same origin
gases in the atmosphere
[Music]
the sky above the endless blue expanse
doesn't look too different from the
Skies of the modern Earth The Towering
clouds are built from water vapor drawn
from and cycling endlessly with the
great Oceanic expanse meanwhile the
density of air molecules within 100
kilometers of the surface served a
scatter the blue wavelengths of the
sun's white light turning the entire
daytime sky blue
but the makeup of these air molecules is
where the difference lies once again the
traveler can be thankful for the
Hermetic seal on the time machine
because without it they would
immediately suffocate in the archaean
air there is none of the oxygen their
body needs to survive only nitrogen
carbon dioxide and methane though like
today relatively inert nitrogen makes up
the bulk of the atmosphere
carbon-bearing molecules fill the Gap
left by the absence of oxygen making up
some 10 to 15 percent of the air and it
is these that are responsible for many
of the Curious phenomena that beset this
archaean world
firstly the carbon dioxide is the source
of the ocean's acidity carbon dioxide
gas becomes carbonic acid in the water
raising the ph and speeding up the
chemical erosion of the exposed ocean
floor these carbon-rich molecules are
also the source of the otherworldly Haze
that tints the upper Skies with a pale
orange Hue when light from the sun
strikes the methane carbon dioxide and
nitrogen molecules at the top of the
atmosphere it begins a chain of chemical
reactions that produces larger
carbon-bearing organic molecules with
greater capacity for scattering light
this organic Haze is similar to that
which shrouds Saturn's moon Titan today
although on the early Earth it is much
thinner and more diffuse allowing more
of the sun's weak light to penetrate and
considering that weak light it is also
the carbon dioxide and methane in the
atmosphere that solves this apparent
Paradox of a tropical climate in spite
of the faint young Sun both of these
carb enrich molecules a powerful
greenhouse gases able to trap the
infrared radiation that bounces from the
earth keeping it close to the surface
and swaddling the planet in an
insulating layer of heat much higher
concentrations of greenhouse gases lead
to more heat being trapped despite the
fact that less heat is being delivered
in the first place
and so this balmy ocean and its humid
hazy Sky really owe their existence to
the invisible molecules in the archaean
air
a part of the traveler longs to dip
their toes in the warm Waters the lap
against the capsule's windows but
without any breathing Aid they cannot
risk cracking the seal that is keeping
them safe
and so they sit and watch calmly as the
sun sinks readily below the flat Horizon
and the sky
filled with stars
the orange hazy glow of daytime is
replaced with dramatic curtains of light
as the Aurora drapes itself over these
Southern latitudes unlike the Green
Tinted Southern Lights of the modern day
these auroras are predominantly blue and
red another reminder of the
nitrogen-rich oxygen poor atmosphere
Beyond
thank you
all around the capsule there is no land
in sight despite this being the period
in which the most ancient rocks of
Western Australia formed because of
course they are forming at the bottom of
the ocean from sand and mud grains
eroded from the sea floor itself
this is a time before land before
continents and it will be a billion
years or more until the rocks that are
forming now eventually see these Stars
the Endless Ocean the dark empty depths
and the crushing pressure of an
unbreathable atmosphere way heavily on
The Traveler
at the very least they will need to find
an atmosphere they can breathe and
although life is making a burgeoning
beginning at the bottom of the dark
ocean it is still a bit player on the
planetary stage
they cannot stay here
on the 18th of February 2021 after an
interplanetary journey of some 480
million kilometers the perseverance
Rover touched down on the surface of
Mars
The Descent and Landing had been
nail-biting for the hundreds of
scientists and Engineers involved in its
development as the spacecraft deployed
parachutes reverse Jets and eventually a
hovering crane to decelerate the
car-sized Rover from a cruising speed of
nearly 40 000 kilometers per hour to
deliver the Rover safely and slowly to
the ground
all of these interventions were
necessary because Mars has just one
percent of the atmosphere that Earth
does so the spacecraft couldn't rely on
the air itself to slow it down but after
seven long minutes in which the landing
sequence unfolded automatically as
planned perseverance did touch down in
one functioning piece to begin its
operations on the Martian's surface
generations of Mars rovers have now been
sent to the red planet to study it Trace
its geological history and prepare for
future manned and returning missions
both future colonists and returning
spacecraft will need certain resources
already there when they arrive Chief
among them being oxygen for breathing
and for rocket fuel
but Mars has a little oxygen of its own
its thin atmosphere naturally contains
less than a sixth of a percent of the
critical gas and so the perseverance
Rover carried an experimental instrument
on board called the Mars oxygen in situ
resource utilization experiment
shortened to moxie which was designed to
test a new technology for making the
oxygen future missions would need
this technology works by taking the more
abundant carbon dioxide from the Martian
air and using exotic mineral catalysts
and temperatures around 800 degrees
Celsius to split the molecule into its
component parts oxygen which can be
trapped and stored and carbon monoxide
that's released back into the air
and in April 2021 after just a few
months on the planet's surface Moxie
succeeded in its task over the course of
around one hour the instrument made 5.3
grams of oxygen literally from thin air
oh
this is about the same production as you
might get from a modest sized tree and
is enough to supply an astronaut with
breathable air for about 10 minutes
clearly improvements need to be made as
the technology is scaled up in order for
it to be sustainable but nonetheless
scientists celebrated their success as a
first step towards long term manned Mars
missions
as impressive as this first feat of
terraforming is it is ultimately a pale
imitation of a process that is happening
all over the Earth every minute of every
day and which was first Mastered by
microbes at least 2.4 billion years ago
considering their next temporal jump our
traveler recalls that one of the major
transitions in the evolution of life on
Earth happened around two and a half
billion years ago this is the paleo
protozoic and a period of Earth's
history known grandly as the great
oxidation event
and so the traveler finishes the
calculations starts the machine and
makes the leap
prior to this time microbial life had
evolved and colonized the deeper oceans
surviving off the chemical energy in
certain inorganic minerals as well as
the heat emitted from submarine volcanic
Vents and they did very well there
constructing layered microbial
metropolises with separate castes of
Life utilizing successive byproducts
from these early metabolisms but their
colonization ultimately met a dead end
even a few meters away from the sources
of such energy these chemotropic
microbes would be forever confined to
the few disparate parts of the deep
ocean with the energy to sustain them
while the rest of the planet remained
Barren and uninhabited
that was until a revolution in microbial
metabolism changed the way things could
be done instead of deriving energy from
heat the appearance of certain pigment
molecules allowed microbes to use the
energy from the Sun and to accompany
this bottomless Feast of energy these
Innovative life forms turned to the
abundance of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere and water in the ocean to
provide the raw nutrition for metabolism
and growth whether in a single
evolutionary flash of Brilliance or as
is more likely a few million years of
stumbling stepwise Innovation
photosynthesis was invented captured
sunlight splits carbon dioxide and water
molecules which are then reassembled
into energy storing sugars and oxygen as
the byproduct the sugars help the
photosynthesizing microbes survive while
the oxygen is released as waste back
into the ocean and atmosphere
paleontologists cannot be sure exactly
when this metabolic revolution occurred
tracing the gene evolution of modern
photosynthesizing microbes called
cyanobacteria puts their origin around
2.7 billion years ago and although some
fossils have been recovered from much
earlier strata that seem to resemble
them the geological evidence for
large-scale oxygen production doesn't
seem to appear until the turn of the
proterozoic
and so photosynthetic metabolisms
evolved which resulted in oxygen being
released in great quantity fundamentally
altering the kinds of rocks that were
created around this time but this oxygen
was also poisonous to many of the
ecosystems that thrived at this time and
so the very process that gave them a
life also stifled and suffocated them
the earliest years of photosynthesis
would therefore stop start pulsing and
pausing as ecosystems died off and
recovered causing vast Global Extinction
events before eventually finding their
feet in a new oxygenated World Order
[Music]
The Traveler has their eyes on the
atmospheric composition readouts as the
time machine arrives at this turning
point in Earth's history and is
satisfied to see the percentage of
oxygen in the air creep up to one two
three four percent this is a good sign
confirmation of the signals in the rocks
that photosynthesis has arrived on the
scene and has begun to transform the
atmosphere with its waste product but at
four percent it stalls unchanging not
Rising any higher this they quickly
realize won't be enough to breathe for
that they will need at least 10 percent
oxygen and preferably much more
frustrated they finally tear their eyes
away from the dashboard to the windows
they're surprised to once again see a
world
completely transformed
for beyond the metallic Port it is white
as far as the eye can see
land forms are laid out before them
Foothills rise to mountains in the
distance and a flat expanse that could
be an ocean stretches out over to one
side
but it is all white covered in ice and
snow with just the occasional Rocky
Bluff showing through where it's been
swept clean by the wind
already ice crystals begin to grow
around the edges of the window glass The
Traveler will not be able to see from
their singular viewpoint but this icy
terrain extends around much of the globe
from the poles to the tropics ocean
surfaces of frozen solid Rivers iced
over and snow is blown into towering
drifts that are also Frozen in place
they have jumped into the near Global
huronian glaciation which gripped the
planet for some 300 million years
following the great oxygenation event
photosynthesizing organisms colonizing
the shallow Seas of the paleoproterozoic
Drew in carbon dioxide reducing its
concentration in the atmosphere
meanwhile the oxygen emitted reacted
with the methane in the air turning it
into carbon dioxide and water that also
became fuel for photosynthesis with this
new microbial metabolism the two
powerful greenhouse gases that were
holding in heat and insulating the
planet against a faint young Sun became
suddenly depleted and the Earth was left
quite literally
out in the cold
and so the traveler has found the
origins of photosynthesis and the
beginning of atmospheric oxygen but it
isn't enough there is still not enough
of the gas to breathe and the balmy
tropical waters that had been so
inviting are now a thing of the past
they simply have no choice but to keep
moving forward in time to try and find
when the world becomes hospitable once
again
this time now accustomed to the dizzying
acceleration and deceleration in time
they try a new approach to piloting the
temporal expanse instead of selecting a
Target date for the machine to reach
they switch the controls into manual and
ease the lever forwards
as before the days and nights blend
together and the sun blurs into a streak
that sways back and forth across the sky
with Seasons but the land remains white
around them Global glaciations like
these are not easily shifted and they
see the Millennia tick by with scarcely
any change
it's only around 2.2 billion years ago
that the color returns to the world and
the traveler watches red tinge landscape
around them grow with mountain building
smooth out and shrink back with
weathering and erosion the temperatures
are more Clement but the oxygen fails to
rise any further it is resolutely stuck
at four percent
as the date ticks past 1.6 billion BCE
The Traveler passes notionally into the
mesopoterozoic but there is little
change to show for it
[Music]
this entire era languishes within a
period of Earth's history known as the
boring billion and even with this
temporarily averaged view it is clear
how it earned its name
for about a billion years between 1.8
and 0.8 billion years ago very little
changes at all
the landscape undulates around the
capsule the shorelines creeped forward
and back but there are no dramatic
flashes of Ice Age catastrophic stormy
Seasons or bursts of photosynthetic
green if anything the world looks less
inviting with each passing moment
Seas or a blackish purple color
Testament to their ongoing General lack
of oxygen and the chemosynthetic
microbes that are able to colonize them
the atmospheric readings point to
elevated levels of hydrogen sulfide in
the coastal air as well and the
paleontologist hopes their Mind is
Playing Tricks on them as they think
they detect a faint with of rotten eggs
cannot stay like this forever they know
that beneath the calm unchanging surface
of the boring billion there is a frenzy
of evolutionary activity the stability
of these Millennia is allowing microbes
to experiment with new means of getting
energy and new Cooperative ways of life
eager to see the fruits of these
evolutionary labors they push the lever
forward to its furthest reach and press
onwards to the Neo protozoic
in many ways the modern landscape of the
northwest of Scotland is reminiscent of
the same location some billions of years
earlier the notched shorelines and
Inland locks are rimmed with Rocky
outcrops that slope gently into the
calmly lapping Waters eroding slowly
into fine sand and mud that sinks to the
lake bottom just as it did in the
neoproterozoic looking past the modern
day Heather and stunted trees the
shorelines are washed with rubbery
seaweeds that belong to more primitive
algol families but if you scrape back
those living algae and expose the
ancient rocks beneath you will find
ripples frozen into the fine-grained
sediment adorned with the lace-like
patterns of Tufts wrinkles and pustules
these are the delicate traces left by Al
gomats That Grew and colonized the
shoreline a billion years ago a sign
that photosynthetic life had taken the
next step onto the land
and into
the light
Halfway Around the Globe and a thousand
million years in the past the traveler
Witnesses this change in the ecosystem
first hand
even though there has been life in the
oceans for nion two and a half billion
years this is the first time that it
becomes visible to the naked eye around
the edges of the oceans now returned to
a healthier gray blue that reflects the
sky there was an unmistakable tinge of
green the photosynthesizing organisms in
the water are still largely microscopic
but they are present in such number that
they cannot be missed
the retreating tide leaves behind a scum
of frothy green microbes buoyed by the
air trapped beneath their interlocking
fibers and a quick glance at the
atmospheric readings confirms what the
color change suggests
photosynthesis is now so well
established in the surface oceans and
its carbon dioxide drawdown and oxygen
production so efficient that the oxygen
concentration in the atmosphere has
finally risen after around one and a
half billion years of frustrating stasis
now in the year 750 million BCE oxygen
levels have jumped to a little less than
20 percent of the entire atmospheric
composition and for the first time in
their Journey The Fragile human traveler
will be able to breathe the ancient air
beyond the capsule
they waste no time with a final check
that confirms the temperature is safe
and that there are no toxic surprises
looking Beyond The Machine's warping
glass they crank the handle to break the
seals
a faint hiss as the pressure
equilibrates and their nose is suffused
with the smells of the neoproterozoic
air
after the cool sterile but increasingly
stuffy microcosm inside the capsule the
sensation is one of stepping off a plane
on some tropical aisle
there is humidity warmth and the vague
Aroma of salt and Decay drifting up from
the beach breathing deeply The Traveler
soaks in this ancient air before
swinging their legs out and onto the
baron Rocky ground
wanting more than anything to run to the
water explore everything they can see
they hold themselves back oxygen
concentrations are still not enough to
support their muscles under any kind of
exertion so they take it slowly step by
step
they feel a little light-headed but
that's not just because of the oxygen
deficiency
there is also a small but detectable
quantity of nitrous oxide laughing gas
in the air
this nitrous oxide is a consequence of
the complex nitrogen chemistry that has
been made possible by this new
supercharged surge of life and it is
helping to keep the planet warm despite
the extra draw on its carbon dioxide
reserves with careful steps the
paleontologist approaches the shore and
reaching the still wet sand they probe
the accumulated organic matter with
their boots before scooping it with
their hand it is cool slimy and up close
appears in a spectrum of Hues and
textures from fibrous green filaments
and froth to sturdier rubbery red tinge
structures like seaweed without anything
to graze upon it these primitive algae
coat the shoreline as it disappears into
the distance drying out and rotting
where they sit and the hole intertidal
flat is turned Black by the breakdown of
such abundant organic matter
Shadow passes across the Sun and For the
First Time The Traveler looks up from
the life on the beach to the dark gray
of a developing storm out to sea the
warm temperature over the shallow oceans
provide the ideal fuel for evaporation
winds and violence Cyclones that will
soon come and inundate this living
diorama like so many tropical island
holidays the scene can switch all too
quickly from calm to cataclysm with the
arrival of a single storm
The Traveler is suddenly aware of how
exposed they are on the open beach with
only the low undulating dunes and the
decaying algae for company when the
storm strikes there will be no cover or
Shelter From the Deluge and as they
watch The thunderheads Grow Over the
Horizon they don't like to contemplate
there or the time machine's fate in the
face of such natural violence
and as if On Cue their stomach rumbles
they are reminded that shelter isn't the
only thing they would need in order to
extend their trip in the neoproterozoic
they've lost track of how long they have
spent traveling through the expanse of
Earth's history but their body has not
they need to eat
unfortunately these slimy fermenting
algae are not only unappetizing despite
sharing biological structure with their
modern counterparts they're likely to be
indigestible to the modern human stomach
so often no real nutrition
if the traveler is going to be able to
stay anywhere in the past for any amount
of time they will need to find both food
and shelter
with dragging feet and the beginnings of
a headache they reluctantly trudge back
up the dunes to the confines of the time
machine
once again
[Music]
in 1921 a famed Arctic Explorer
wilhelmer stefanson organized an
ambitious expedition to the remote to
Wrangle island of the Northeast Coast of
Siberia with the goal of claiming the
island for Britain
perhaps it was foreshadowing that
stefanson never intended to be part of
the Expedition at all but instead sent
four brave but ultimately inexperienced
British men along with a young Native
Alaskan woman Ada Blackjack as cook and
seamstress Ada may have been native to
the icy world of Alaska but she had been
brought up a Methodist and knew nothing
of the indigenous survival techniques
she was as much a novice in these icy
Wilds as the men she accompanied
the five managed to last out on the
island for almost a year but the
Expedition Came Upon hard times as
summer turned to Winter one of the men
became Gravely ill with scurvy and the
other three elected to leave him and Ada
behind in search of better fortunes
elsewhere
they were never heard from again Edo
continued to care for the sick and
bedridden man alone until his eventual
death
but that was not to be her end instead
teaching herself many fundamental
survival skills she learned to shoot and
trap to produce them with food built
shelter and polar bear Lookout platforms
with Driftwood and storage boxes and
even built herself a boat from animal
skins after the Brit's death she
survived entirely alone on the island
for three long months and when a boat
eventually arrived in search of the
missing Expedition two years after it
had set out its crew found only Ada
alone in the Arctic wilderness
foreign
the time traveling paleontologist Pilots
their craft with confidence now easing
through the Millennia
as the landscape flashes by they are
left with time to wander to think about
what it is humans really need to survive
the absolute Basics to begin with we
need air we can breathe and that means
oxygen we need a temperature that our
bodies can sustain in and depending on
the humidity and the clothes available
to us that means anything from a few
degrees above freezing to perhaps 50
degrees Celsius
we need water to drink to sustain our
basic metabolic processes so that water
must be above freezing to be liquid and
clean enough to not cause its own raft
of problems we need food to sustain our
metabolisms too including the energy
rich carbohydrates found in grains and
vegetables and the bodybuilding proteins
found in pulses and animal flesh
and because nothing in the natural world
ever stays the same we need shelter to
protect us whether that be from violent
swings in weather temperature or the
threat of the living components of the
ecosystem
and so in their travels it has taken the
paleontologist some 4 billion years to
get to the temperature water and air
that are the most critical for immediate
survival but they have yet to find the
food and shelter that will allow them to
endure
flickering forward through the second
half of the neoproterozoic the
Landscapes which is periodically between
the colorful Hues of a temperate coast
and the oppressive monochrome of a
glacial world just as it was nearly 2
billion years before these glaciations
are Global in extent turning the entire
Earth into a featureless icy snowball
but the new abundance and diversity of
life in the shallow oceans is able to
cling on in slushy warm refugia around
the equator and near volcanic hot spots
and it bounces back with a Gusto at the
first hint of warming temperatures
the last of these planets spanning
glaciers Fades away and the traveler
slows their craft to a stop
this they know is the idiacaran
the most recently defined period of
Earth's history the idiacaran was only
recognized as an error in its own right
in 2004 and so though it is not
immediately apparent on a rival there is
a revolution in animal life taking place
where before there had only been
bacteria and algae there is now
something completely different which the
Earth has never seen before or since
the environment beyond the capsule is
once again warm and tropical and the
oxygen levels are even closer to what
the Traveler's body needs so they are
quick to leave the craft behind on the
shore and wade into the shallows in Hope
of seeing these remarkable life forms
for themselves
the idiacaran biota has flummoxed
geologists for decades they exist as the
first truly macroscopic life but their
preservation as impressions in soft sand
mud and volcanic ash means that we still
don't know much about how their bodies
are constructed some live in the ocean
depths far from the reach of the Sun and
are thought to get their food from the
decaying organic matter in the sea floor
mud itself others can be found in
shallower Sandy environments of river
deltas where the sun dapples the sea
floor and waves constantly shift the
substrate and its bizarre inhabitants
entering the water up to their knees and
kneeling down to peer through the glassy
shallows the paleontologist searches for
these curious ediacarans like a child
might search a rock pool for shrimp
it is not long before they spot their
Quarry flattened dickinsonia flopping
along the sand spragina flapping like
loose ribbons from their shallow anchors
and shield-shaped Parvin Carina squat to
the sand but aligned with the Rippling
waves
these strange animal-like creatures seem
unaware of or at least unable to react
to the hulking human casting Shadows
above them and the paleontologist is
easily able to reach out and touch them
running their fingers along their
rubbery quilted flesh
with no skeleton shell or really any
digestive tract that they could see
there was little preparation needed
after a little boiling in seawater they
had the texture somewhere between
oysters and Squid
doubtless in enough quantity these
idiacarans could provide the body with
the protein it needed to sustain itself
but the knowledge of these creatures
Rarity leaves a sour taste in the mouth
The Traveler May well be the first to
eat a creature that has been extinct for
half a billion years but they won't be
complicit in that Extinction
proper food and shelter should be found
closer to home
there is a legend the geological
prospector Charles Doolittle Walcott was
riding with his family and an
expeditionary party along a trail in the
Canadian Rockies of British Columbia
when his wife's horse stumbled and
tripped on a rock splitting it open in
the process
dismounting Walcott rushes to the broken
rock rather than his wife's Aid to find
it packed with curious flattened shapes
that he recognizes as fossils the party
worked their way up the slope to find
the source of this Bountiful Rock and
eventually discover a paleontological
bounty like nothing anyone had seen
before
this so-called Burgess Shale contained
organic fossils of a multitude of
strange animals perfectly preserved by
their black muddy internment over the
next several years Walcott LED parties
back to the Shale collecting more than
60 000 specimens of remarkably preserved
soft-bodied animals or dating to solve
the earliest moments of the Cambrian
Period and this veritable explosion of
animal life
and it is during this eponymous Cambrian
explosion parked up at a date of 500
million years BCE that the traveler
finally finds a seafood Feast that
carries no guilt
the same seas that had played host to
the helpless fleshy ediacarans that
flopped and flapped on the Sandy surface
now hold an almost unfathomable Treasure
of swimming squirming and burrowing
animal life
Shelley brachyports like clams and
cockles cluster among jointed-legged
arthropods including trilobites of every
size and shape thus free swimming
anomalocaris and opapinia predators
adorned with pincers and prongs
a circus of worms mix up the seafloor
sediment while hallucigenia probes the
Disturbed surface protected from
overhead attack by its Mohawk of pointed
spines Eli picaya squirms through the
shallow Waters while many more
unfamiliar animal shapes drift close to
and above the surface
the paleontologist can eat their fill of
this protein-rich banquet and never make
a dent in the population as a whole
but protein is only part of the balanced
diet that a survivalist needs Inuits of
the Modern Age make do on an exclusively
animal diet by making the most of what
those animals have to offer including
their bones blubber even gut contents
but these primitive Cambrian animals are
more flesh than bone and their
ecosystems too immature for
paleogastronomist to glean much more not
to mention that these warm tropical
life-filled oceans are still prone to
Violent storms from which there is no
hope of shelter
and so forward still The Traveler must
continue
[Music]
following the eruption of animal life in
the Seas during the Cambrian the next to
logical step for biology is towards the
as yet uncolonized land surfaces however
this is a process much easier said than
done as bare rock and chemically
weathered Sands offer little in the way
of nutrition or support for burgeoning
life
it takes a succession of algae fungi
lichen and squat spreading land plants
to Brave the elements and build the
first soils from the bottom up
and so it isn't until some 50 million
years later during the order Vision
period that the time traveler encounters
the first life on land capable of
casting a shadow
but these are no shreves
they're actually a skyscraper of a
fungus known as prototaxities
smooth and featureless monoliths rise up
to 8 meters in height standing proud and
sturdy with trunks that can be one meter
in diameter where decays these these
Mighty mushrooms felled their trunks lie
chaotically across the landscape swathed
in smaller plants and swarmed by insects
some of the first animal Pioneers to
colonize the land
The Traveler spent a little time
exploring this Founder's landscape and
can imagine making use of prototaxities
to build a shelter should the need arise
but with the world transforming so fast
around them now they are Keen to see how
things change throughout the rest of the
Paleozoic and Beyond
taking away millions of years by the
second it is just a short hop from the
order Vision to the devonian of 400
million years ago and then to the
Carboniferous of 300 million years BCE
The Limited fungal forest is supplanted
by a succession of plants and trees with
an Ever broadening diversity of shapes
sizes and approaches to photosynthesis
the once Baron Rocky land surfaces are
transformed to a spongy alomi soil
pierced by coniferous forest as far as
the eye can see here for the first time
the trees alone are able to provide
Shelter From the elements and walking
among their densely crowded trunks The
Traveler finds themselves cast in a
green hued Gloom from which it is
difficult to Glimpse the sky
meanwhile in the oceans the bizarre life
forms of the Cambrian have also been
succeeded by an overwhelming diversity
of fish ancestors of the multitudes that
we know of today the first trees as well
as providing comforting shelter also
provide the traveler turned Hunter with
the tools needed to capture their prey
as they fashion sharpened Spears from
discarded branches and wade into the
shallows to track down a daily catch
it feels like the ultimate Wilderness
Adventure in this Carboniferous world
but it is not a place that can sustain
the traveler in the long term
while the ever-increasing diversity of
vegetation and animal life offers a much
more varied diet than ever before much
of it remains beyond the reach of the
human stomach the trees and plants all
belong to a group known as gymnosperms
which reproduce with seeds contained in
cones rather than fruits and as such are
of little nutritional value despite
their impressive size and morphological
variety they are no more digestible than
the seaweed scum that rotted on the
neoproterozoic shore to meet the body's
carbohydrate energy needs the traveler
needs to travel one more time
and so now they make their final jump
skipping forward another 180 million
years into the future to near the close
of the Mesozoic
when paleontologists first discovered
the 120 million year old fossil of a
raven-sized long-tailed bird called jail
lornas they saw it surrounded by a
scattering of seeds as if its stomach
contents had exploded during its burial
and fossilization the researchers first
thought this pointed to a diet that like
many before it consisted of the seeds
commonly produced by conifers and other
gymnosperms of the Cretaceous forests
but there was a number of things about
jail ornes that didn't quite add up in
order to get enough nutrition from these
tough seeds Birds typically swallow
small stones to produce a kind of
internal gastric Mill that would help to
break them down inside the body but the
jail honest fossils had no sign of
gastric stones and they didn't have the
sort of beak or mouth structures that
would allow them to break down the seeds
either how could these large birds get
enough nutrients from their diet
the obvious solution lay in what was not
being preserved in the fossil record but
which was nevertheless implied by other
Clues left behind
jehalones was not eating seeds on their
own
but rather feasted on soft fruit
the nutrition came from the sugary
fruiting structures of a newly evolved
kind of plant and the seeds were merely
an indigestible byproducts dating to the
middle of the Cretaceous Period
jayalornis became the first fruit-eating
bird that paleontologists had ever
identified
gymnosperm plants still live among us
today as pine trees cypresses cycads and
ginkgo's and they remain just as
indigestible as they were 300 million
years ago instead all of the plant
products that we enjoy in our diets
today belong to a different plant group
called
angiosperms
foreign
ly known as flowering plants they
surround their seeds in fleshy ovaries
that can become modified in a multitude
of ways to encourage different styles of
dispersion and germination it is only
these fleshy Parts in addition to other
carbohydrate-rich modifications to help
such plants survive that humans can
digest with ease and angiosperms make
their appearance surprisingly late in
Earth's history with the first fossil
pollen from flowering plants discovered
in rocks dating 140 million years ago to
the early Cretaceous but once on the
scene their Superior means of
reproduction allowed them to quickly
rise to dominance and just 20 million
years later as the jalornis fossils show
they had become an essential part of the
food chain
[Music]
and so this is where we find our time
traveling paleontologist finally at the
end of their Journey
The Time Machine sits empty and powered
down with only the current year showing
on the dimmed and Dusty screen
these are the latter years of the
Mesozoic and the later years of the
Great Age of Dinosaurs the diverse
landscape of forests and plains are
punctuated by these terrible lizards in
herds and as individuals while primitive
Birds flit between the ground and the
trees diminutive mammals skittering
between Burrows in the dusty soil the
more dangerous theropod predators are
Porsches stalkers sticking to the
Shadows while crowds of hulking
vegetarians like frilled triceratops and
armored ankylosaurs all Feast on the
plant Bounty of a mixed gymnosperm and
angiosperm Forest
and among them a small human figure
collects fruits and nuts from The
ancestral flowering plants within their
reach they will be the perfect balanced
complement to the Cretaceous meat and
seafood that they have become Adept at
trapping and catching and which wait for
them in the basic shelter they have
built among the ancient pine trees at
the edge of the plain
this finally is a life that will sustain
after traveling through nearly 4 billion
years of Earth's history the
paleontologist has found a place that
they can truly survive
and endure they found water in the
archaean and first encountered bearable
temperatures in that great Eon as well
although they learned never to take the
long-term climate for granted they were
forced to travel three and a half
billion years into the neoproterozoic
before they found air they could breathe
and onwards another half billion to the
Cambrian for a proper meal shelter only
came in the Carboniferous after plants
learned how to grow tall and strong
while a balanced diet with enough fiber
and energy to keep them healthy could
not be found until now in the mid
Cretaceous
with just 100 million years separating
them from their temporal origin it is
perhaps surprising that such survival
could not be found sooner is it a result
of the changeable face of our planet or
of the fragility and specialization of
modern humans
Perhaps it is both
nevertheless this
is it
100 million years ago is the earliest in
time a human could really survive and
the young settler now neither a
paleontologist or a traveler intends to
stay in this ancient Paradise
for as long
as they can
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to like And
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
foreign